welcome to yang speaks the awesome
awesome rasheed hey costume how are you
i'm good andrew how are you good to see
you it's good to see you too
so i feel like you and i had a a bunch
in common
where uh are you an immigrant or the son
of immigrants
i'm an immigrant i'm an immigrant i was
four
you were four it counts man it counts i
mean uh you must remember uh
arriving here um but the other thing we
have in common is that we both have a
legal background
though you became a civil rights lawyer
um
and uh community activist uh whereas i
did something much more so
sucking for five months you know i did
the corporate i did the corporate law
thing for
a couple of years uh because you know
you need the
paycheck to pay your student loans but
you're right it can be soul-sucking if
it's not the right fit for you and
that's what helped me make the ultimate
jump to
civil rights and human rights work
full-time yeah so tell us a little bit
more about the civil rights
legal work that you did over that period
of years uh because you built like a
very strong following
on the basis of fighting for people yeah
you know i think a lot of it goes back
to
what my parents ingrained and my
siblings and i at a very young age so
whatever you do in life
if you're not centering service to
humanity it's really a waste of your
life and that was the word that they
used
and so as i got older that was the lens
with which how i looked at everything
and going to law school really opened my
eyes to
kind of understanding the incredible
role the law plays
in whether people have basic access to
decency and dignity or not
and in law school i got involved with a
non-profit here in virginia
called the virginia poverty law center
their office of domestic and sexual
violence
and so it started from a very early
point in my legal career supporting
women who are survivors and that's
pro-bono work i do
through this day i started working with
non-profits on expanding health care and
education access on disaster relief was
the prison chaplain and you know all
this to say that
um when you get to understand how folks
are struggling
on the front lines you really begin to
understand and you know
on the theme of you and i having a lot
in common andrew you really begin to
understand that these aren't republican
or democrat issues these are
basic human issues and it's critical
that we stand together and work together
and address these
one of the most rewarding jobs i had was
at a women's rights organization in dc
where we were able to work with the
department of justice and other
various government entities on just
ensuring and advising that the policies
being put before
really do give people equal access under
the law that's really what this has to
be about
yeah you're a humanist and humanitarian
first and foremost i feel
it's one reason i like you is that um
you have a very elevated perspective on
a lot of these issues
you're running in a relatively rural
part of virginia
um that's been somewhat republican
leaning but it's going purple right now
and i think you've got a great chance to
win i think you're gonna have a lot of
wind at
your back uh can you tell us a little
bit more
about your opponent um and your district
and the race the state of the race
how is causing race shaping up well so
the race is going great let me start
with my opponent career politician he's
been in office 34 years
and uh you know pretty heavily corporate
funded uh hasn't
really made the most kosher decisions
financially bought himself
stock in a pharmaceutical company
working on corporate 19
treatment way back in february and then
told us the virus is low risk and not
spreading and
you know his entire approach this entire
campaign has been to attack me for my
faith
tried to tie me to islamic terrorism and
just all sorts of ridiculous things
that's never been my style and we're not
going to respond in kind
this is a district you know if you visit
virginia you get to
really see southern hospitality and this
is a district where people
really enjoy being in each other's
company they enjoy
uh you know talking to complete
strangers and there's this
sense of civility and and i think honor
and dignity in the folks here that i've
seen
where even if you are from a different
perspective or different faith or
different racial background
you're treated with a lot of respect and
i really enjoyed that about living
in virginia and raising our children
here the race
has been going extraordinarily well and
the early voter turnout
um shows us with a massive lead about
136
000 votes have been cast so far and
we're looking at the polling that we've
done
on people who've already voted right now
we
are getting over 70 of the vote and so
for us
it's about you know continuing that uh
that trend
pushing folks to the polls making sure
we're winning
the folks on the fence and uh we're
having event after event where now
republicans and trump supporters are
showing up and we're welcoming them in
and it's been a really powerful
experience so far
i had the same experience on the trail
costume where i would show up places
where there were frankly not like you
know that many asian americans
uh in some of the early states but
people will listen to you uh they'll
realize if you're there for the right
reasons
people just want to be respected and
heard and if you respect and hear them
then they'll respect and hear you
and then they'll figure out it's like
wait a minute this person actually
uh here's my experience it's like they
they spend some time with you
and they realize that there are only two
possibilities one that you're
an absolute crazy person or two that
you're genuinely there to help
and then when they get rid of number one
they're like wait this person is
actually sincere
and that's that's very very powerful
stuff
like you know we can draw in people from
uh both sides of the aisle because
americans
in my mind are unified and being fed up
right now
uh you know and they're like different
strains of uh fed up-ness
but the the fed upness is near universal
and if you seem like a genuine
um public servant and humanist who wants
to help them and their families
they'll support you well and we saw that
yesterday we had an event
uh here in the district which about you
know 30 people showed up not a massive
event but certainly not tiny it was a
good
good crowd and and we had a big rasheed
for congress sign behind me
so folks who are trump supporters
started driving by honking you know
trump 2020 with the trump flags
and and you know we ignored it and then
a whole bunch of them
showed up carrying a trump flag uh and
just kind of yelling and screaming
and i paused the event and i had the
microphone so i
i kind of raised my voice to the trump
supporters and i was like hey guys you
don't need to yell
you can be part of this conversation too
why don't you come on in
and i think i caught them off guard
because i think they expected me to kind
of shout them out i said
come on in let's have a conversation i
got their name one the guy's name was
chad and we actually had a pretty
meaningful
conversation um you know i refuse to
respond to the vitriol but at the end of
the day
after the event ended andrew out of
these 30 people five of them walked up
to me one by one
and said i'm a lifelong republican i
have never voted democrat
in my entire life i feel like i don't
really have a party i wasn't sure where
to vote
but now after seeing the way you treat
people even if they disagree with you
you've got my vote and i'm like that's
brilliant because that's exactly what
i'm trying there are so many people who
feel
politically adrift right now because if
you're a lifelong republican and you
look up at
donald trump and you say this is not
what i signed up for like you know i
voted for this guy last time and like
this has been a crushing
disappointment and uh so then they're
looking around and saying what do i do
and you know you presented
the right kind of unifying figure and
message for them to say
like he's sincere he wants to help uh so
calcium
you are for cash relief like after you
get to congress when's the first time
you
were exposed to a universal basic income
uh like when did you first hear about it
you know so i'm a student of history and
uh there's a great book
by michael hart uh called the 100 where
he
ranks 100 most influential people in
history um it's a great way to sound
really smart by only reading like a five
page excerpt on every you know major
figure in history
and and number 52 uh
was uh or is he ranks a person named
omar who was a second caliph uh after
prophet muhammad and omar was
not just a religious figure but he was
an economic genius
and he introduced this concept of ubi
about 1400 years ago
uh to the you know the arabian peninsula
and to the islamic
empire at that time and it was designed
to be exactly that you know
a guaranteed form of cash payments to
working families to ensure that they
could have a basic level of
livelihood and it helped ignite the
economy and that's actually why michael
hart
dr michael hart ranks him as number 52
because of his economic genius and that
was one of them so
for me this principle is something that
i was fortunate to be exposed to at an
early age
and in my research and study not only
was i
excited to find out that we were close
to passing ubi in the united states back
in the 70s under a republican
president no less but if you look at all
the studies around the world
you find consistent study after study
demonstrating that this not only
uplifts people out of poverty but it
ignites the economy
it advances entrepreneurship and
innovation it creates upward mobility it
decreases rates of suicide
and depression and mental illness and
elevates senses of well-being
and just the overall human experience so
i see
every reason to push forward for this
haven't seen a single valid reason to
to oppose it yes and you're exactly
the the person who's going to help us
pass this thing when we get you into
congress and we'll all be around and say
well
no what what do we do to restore
a path forward for millions of americans
but also to reconstitute a sense of
public trust
and i've organizations and
it's very hard to just go around asking
people to
for their buy-in or their trust or their
confidence unless you
actually step forward yourself and
invest in them like if we as a society
say look you
everyone has intrinsic value your kids
have value
you matter and we're not just going to
[ __ ] you and talk about it like
we're actually going to put our money
where our mouth is like that is actually
the transformative uh
change that people will respond to
because
they're just you people talking to them
and not doing anything and then if you
actually do something that
meaningfully impacts and improves their
life then it's a game changer
and we can make it happen like you're
going to be one of the people that
helps make it happen from the halls of
congress starting 2021
after you win this thing after you win
um
what district are you in virginia and if
someone wants to help you and support
your campaign where do they go how do
they help
we're the first district of virginia you
can go to our website uh
rashid for va.com i'm on social media at
casimir
just my name really really easy to find
and to add to your point i mean there's
a reason andrew that our campaign slogan
is compassion through action that
having compassion in and of itself isn't
enough you need to take action
otherwise it's just a meaningless word
that makes you feel good but doesn't
actually do anything and so
we need to elevate the level of love and
compassion we have for humanity
into meaningful action to get them the
support that they
need and deserve the basic human dignity
food water shelter
healthcare education and clothing and
for those who want to get involved in
our kind of a campaign i don't care what
side of the political aisle you are on
if these values matter to you
check us out rasheedfa.com send us an
email to organizing
rasheedforva.com and we will get you on
board
yes they will get you on board uh i love
it
uh and you're you're beyond a humanist
and human
humanitarian you're like a grand doer
and i love the doer part
because you're right um the only thing
that makes me feel better about a
problem is doing something about it
and we just need more americans to have
that same
uh approach because things suck right
now but if we all did something about it
we could improve things pretty quickly
and one thing you can do that's very
straightforward is help
candidates like costume get into
congress where they can actually start
uh pushing uh the laws of the land in
the right direction
thank you cause um really man i feel
great about your race i think there's
gonna be a very powerful
uh wind at your back that's going to
help blow you
like forward across this metaphorical
finish line
um and uh you're just getting started
it's awesome thank you man good to be
here good to chat with you
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you